HAPPEN.
VOTE FOR MORE OF IT IN NOVEMBER
IF YOU LIKE IT.
SO THE UFC ULTIMATE FIGHTING
CHAMPION HAS BECOME THE FASTEST
GROWING SPORT IN THE WORLD.
WE WANTED TO MEET THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SEAT OF UFC COME A DAY
IN, DANIEL WRIGHT, WHO RUNS IT
LIKE NOBODY ELSE RUNS ANY SPORT.
WE PLAY THE FIRST PART OF OUR
INTERVIEW YESTERDAY.
UFC IS ABOUT MORE THAN BOXING.
IT HAS REPLACED BOXING IN THE
COMBAT FORCES, IT HAS REPLACED A
LOT OF OTHER BOXING LIKE SPORTS.
WERE MAKING A DOCUMENTARY ABOUT
IT.
EMILY ASKED IF WE COULD SEE
WHITE'S PERSONAL OFFICE BECAUSE
WE HEARD IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
HOPEFULLY WE CAPTURED A SENSE OF
IT ON TAPE.
HERE IT IS.
>> I LOVE THIS.
IS THAT REAL?
>> THAT'S REAL.
THAT'S A SABER-TOOTH TIGER.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE NICEST
SABER-TOOTH TIGER'S GOAL YOU
WILL EVER SEE.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> FIRST THE GUN.
IT REPRESENTS WAR.
WAR IS ALL ABOUT KILLING AND
MONEY AND THE KNIFE.
AND THEN IT'S ALL THE THINGS WE
KILL FOUR.
MONEY, COCAINE, OIL.
THEN THE ARTIST FOUND OUT I
HEADED AND SHOWED UP AND GAVE ME
THE GRENADE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
WHOA, LOOK AT THAT!
>> I LIKE SHOES.
SOME OF THESE ARE THE RAREST
SHOES IN THE WORLD.
AIR JORDANS AND NIKES, ALL THAT
STUFF.
>> Tucker: THAT'S QUITE A
COLLECTION.
>> I HAVE A CRAZY COLLECTION.
AND THIS IS WHAT I'M ADDICTED TO
RIGHT NOW.
I START WITH THE COALS, GO TO
THE HEAT, I DO IT THREE OR FOUR
TIMES IN MY OWN GYM.
>> Tucker: YOUR JIM?
>> YES.
I WORK OUT EVERY MORNING AND I
START MY DAY HERE.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AND DEVELOPING.
WHEN YOU WORK OUT IN THE SPORT,
YOU'VE GOT TO GET SOMEBODY TO
HOLD THE PADS FOR YOU.
SO WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY'S OF THESE GUYS DON'T NEED
SOMEBODY TO HOLD THE PADS.
YOU GOT A GUY OUT HERE TELLING
YOU WHAT TO THROW, WHAT TO DO.
WE BEEN TO DEVELOPING MISSING
FOR COUPLE OF YEARS.
>> Tucker: HOW'S IT WORKING?
THERE'S SOME RESISTANCE THERE.
>> IT'S COMING TOGETHER.
YOU CAN PUNCH, KNEE, KICK.
YOU CAN DO EVERYTHING.
>> Tucker: AMAZING!
>> Tucker: WHAT AN INTERESTING
GUY, AND WHAT A DECENT GUY.
YOU DON'T RUN INTO TOO MANY
PEOPLE LIKE THAT.
OUR DOCUMENTARY AB